hello hi
[Music]
let's see if this is say Nina sorry Nina
Nina yes like an ambulance very good
chance and were you from Janet Minnesota
are you really yes could you just do
sound like you're pretending I'm going
to dress like someone from Minnesota
realize that we're stuck in this utility
room it's about minus three degrees and
there's a dog basket and some coats and
we've watched a bit Bear Grylls I think
we're just gonna after the dog basket
with my friends parents coats all about
is tried to make some bed and realize
that you have to take your clothes off
to stay really warm because it was
really really cold Graham it really was
and a couple of hours late to go by my
friend just starts nudging me at least I
thought he was nudging me but I group my
head spinning so I open my eyes and my
friend is on top of me having sex with a
girl from the party
[Applause]
sorry
no one's could be with banging on the
door we've got no phones there's no
toilet I really really need a way at
this point there's just a bowl so with
the drug basket you know that that
happens then one thing leads to another
in the dog basket and he gets injured
anyway so many bits of this story
missing
so you're having sex in a dog box
who the leave approval IVA great so a
long time ago I went on a date with a
guy who thought he was Indiana Jones
complete with hat and jacket picked me
up in his car and we drove to dinner and
as we were driving to dinner he had a
flaky booger on the end of his nose and
he was telling me his adventuresome
tales because his father was an
archaeologist but I couldn't look at him
because every time I look the booger
would just go ahead
[Applause]
it seems
the story all about how my life got
flipped don't you dare
Thanks hello oh my god
[Applause]
you've been you just yeah what's your
name Mott's
[Applause]
now have you have you made yourself look
like Matt Smith no I think I was born
this way so my husband comes downstairs
one day and announces he is in so much
pain he thinks he's got piles and could
I take a look great opening to anything
he pulls his pants down and I see this
huge shiny red bubble and I'm like oh my
god boy you need to go to the doctor
this isn't God we need to go to the
hospital and he starts laughing and says
I don't need to go to the hospital for
that and pulls out a cherry demotic
you know Jennifer Lawrence says you can
walk
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello good evening
one of her feet had quite a bit of hair
on the top of
she had to injury and had to get two
skin grafts so they took the skin graft
from her pubic area skin started going
back pubic hair on top of her Wow she
was telling me this very nonchalantly oh
now my friends call me pussyfoot haha
therapists you must are someone's [__]
whether it's on there
[Applause]
hi what's your name Cathy cursed are you
from New Zealand as well no I'm from
Beijing steak
I'm a great ear
[Applause]
why is Thomas upset with us um Thomas is
upset because I've postponed a date for
the second time so I could come and be
here opened the door went in and the
lights flipped on but it wasn't my
family who were in the room it was three
fully grown naked men and a woman on the
bed
good story that's so annoying that is
the surprising do you know no I didn't
know them so they forgot the wedding
right no but most Awkward part was I had
to walk over to my bag which was in the
photo so I asked a girl a couple of
weeks ago and she said yes which was
great because she is quite hot and a
joke
[Applause]
say covers you're very key but she's
given you no indication the tears are we
going to flip Thomas go we gonna let
Thomas war okay Kylie please we leave
him off the red Channel
[Applause]
literally dumped Graham Norton here if
you'd like to see even more stuff like
that that hit subscribe or don't it's a
free world but I know what I do in that
situation